I'm a very honest person I can't write
fiction it all has to directly do it
with me or else I can't make the music
by comparison to all of his other albums
this one he really really delves into
past relationships not just like with
girls but just with friends and this
album I'm very proud to say it's just
like I feel like I just told everybody
how I'm actually feeling dropping at
midnight views is released alongside a
beats 1 radio interview that gives fans
at a filtered look at the rapper's most
personal relationships I always have
respected and loved for Nikki and
unfortunately we haven't we haven't
spoke but I mean it is what it is even
if we don't speak she knows what it does
is always loved it Drake opens up to
Zane Lowe about his fractured friendship
with Nicki Minaj sparked by his Twitter
feud with her boyfriend Meek Mill a
conflict that would end in almost
decade-long working relationship these
fly-by-night people that you just come
across I mean they're they're all
they're all not to be trusted but Drake
uses his woes as inspiration for the
album's darkest lyrics friends I don't
have any more guess it's what they say
you need family for sigh can't depend
so who can Drake depend on yeah is one
of my favorite people period like in the
world man we were supposed to do a
mixtape together album together so um
maybe we'll get that done and he adds
even more fuel to those Rihanna romance
rumours I think that's what makes the
records better though because there's
something genuine there we're not like
forcing some story on people I mean it's
you know a lot of the a lot of the music
that we make and the energy that we
bring is is genuine and because the
album's all about Toronto of course
Drake had to be in the city for its big
relief if you want to talk about Drake
views being the most toronto i would say
thousand percent because pretty much the
entire record was produced and written
and recorded in the city six degrees in
the six Drake posts a perfect
temperature just before views drops he's
doing his hometown crowd and critics
coin views as Drake's most Canadian work
yet this is his home this is where he is
the most proud even Canadian news anchor
Peter Mansbridge takes listen judging by
the look on his face if I not be his
style